on a reçu une vidéo parce que il ya
quelqu'un qui nous a fait une régalade
incroyable ce soir vous ai parlé de
soprano depuis le début parce que
cattier c'est vraiment stefania nous ont
fait parvenir une vidéo
regarde moi c'est stefania j'ai 36 ans
je suis maman de trois enfants bientôt
4g ma fille cathy qui a 16 ans
maintenant à qui un cancer en 2010 est
donc on a passé deux années horribles
surtout elle est en fait j'aimerais que
tu lui offre pour noël si c'est possible
un énorme cadeau ce serait la rencontre
avec soprano et le concert ça serait
vraiment super parce qu'elle est
vraiment vraiment fan de lui voilà je
compte sur toi je te fais de gros bisous
alors à la base
4 si elle a dit à stefania elle lui a
fait croire qu'elle nous avait contactés
pour des vacances en famille mais la
vérité c'est que pour noël elle voulait
réaliser son rêve rencontrer soprano
alors du terran ils sont rendus avec
ludivine avec cathy avec l'équipe
d'obama n'est noël pour réaliser une
surprise complètement dingue
regardez ça ça je vous dis c'est ouf et
merci à sopra regarder
[Musique]
tom cat ba ba se donnent pas la messe
mais déjà dans l'ambiance du concert ce
soir au motif travail toi mp comme ça va
merci beaucoup de nous recevoir
avec ce qui s'est avéré au plaisir on a
de la grosse surprise du mois d'août
déjà des gros bisous de babar mais oui
ce serait héros c'est la base c'est la
manne j'ai une jeune fille à se
présenter
vas-y c'est parti on fera comment ça
les prix qu'aux plus tard j'ai découvert
c'est son aspect psy 4 de la rime et
c'est là j'ai découvert soprano c'est un
des artistes ou privés je l'adoré pour
vos soins j'adore c'était super touchant
en 2006 tête j'ai eu un cancer est aussi
que beaucoup touché ça va quand même 10
après le roule parce qu'elle va les
punaises et comme j'étais mettre
d'accord elle est belle ah ouais on peut
toujours le sourire malgré tout ce
qu'elle a vécu exactement exactement là
ce soir pour elle te rencontrer te voir
ce serait le plus beau reste de sa vie
ça fait plaisir parce que franchement je
lui ai préparé une petite surprise
l'année dernière une grosse en même
temps je pense que ça va ça rappelait
tout ça oui j'espère un ami c'est roger
siffer ça va lui plaire
je n'en dis pas plus mais en tout cas
sur 20 sur scène avec vous merci pour l
instant il ya un autre problème
voilà j'ai hâte bon je te laisse te
préparer base y aller
[Musique]
mais chez cathy
cathy est ce que c'est toi ma chérie
est-ce que tu m'invites à rentrer oui
bord génial et maman de quartier ce que
je peux rentrer à venir et comment vous
appelez stefania stefania prévient
stéphane ya et classification à
s'installer
ouais qu'on puisse regarder les yeux
dans les yeux maka qui est donc tu
voulais a participé à baba noël oui tu
as envoyé une vidéo
ouais et où tu nous parler du ta maladie
mais en fait en 2010 sept mois de klaus
ticket un cancer du sang et avec quel
âge en 2017
13 ans 13 ans et comment tu l'as vécu
commentatrice 1 eh bien j'ai pleuré une
fois au début et après et après je ferai
je suis resté un mois à l'hôpital
et après je suis sorti j'ai dit plus la
mesure où tourner et j'ai vécu ma vie
quoi l'une de tes chansons préférées
labrune des maisons préparé une chanson
qui te parle t'on te touchent celles de
sopra nous touche beaucoup
c'est vrai on est pour moi parce que
c'est détection puis semble qu'ils
racontent quelque chose c'est pas des
textes qui vont rien dire ou es tu as
dit rentre ou cool et le régime c'est
vraiment des chances qui me les deux
suédois tu les écoutes et j'espère
porter ça a été magnifique merci ça
qu'il faut que tu te réveilles tu
aimerais partir en vacances avec maman
wilquin jeu maupouet vous pouvez pas
savoir où vous allez partir ce serait
trop facile je vous faire la surprise
jusqu'au bout donc on va vous bander les
yeux
on va vous mettre un casque sur la tête
pour que la surprise soit totale jusqu'à
l'arrivée à l'aéroport c'est d'accord
alors je profite
que vous preniez à lui six minutes pour
me préparer une valise et chacune et
vous partir en vacances avec baba noël
savons pas d'où est ce que vous avez un
peu réfléchi à vous auriez aimé partir
vers los angeles - par la cua oui mais
un bogey sa direction le soleil et le
shopping s'il vous plaît allez c'est
parti tu me dis si tu m'as quelques
cheveux ses vols moyens c'est sûr sur ce
point
[Musique]
oh
l'armada boule au ventre je refais
lourde avec lui
[Musique]
seiler toi qu'est fun de soprano exemple
ça tu l'écouté en boucle quand au site
était malade c'est à dire la force one
les forces
c'est vrai que c'est une personne qui
quand elle a écrit cette chanson elle
pensait aussi à une victime
de la maladie et pour nous ressortir
encore plus forte puisque
l'après qui est dur mais justement nous
savons aussi quand eux se passe pour
vivre mais justement pourquoi après que
familial tout ça c'est une belle
personne soit disant que c'est une
personne entière qui est valable pour du
pipeau pas face toujours hermouet et
vous en tant que maman quand on voit sa
petite fille de 13 ans atteinte d'une
maladie aussi grave mais quand
annoncée on était avec le médecin nous a
poussé le mot cancer
je suis sorti je me suis écroulé par
terre j'ai pleuré toutes les larmes
le premier jour on est non on n'est pas
bien on a des nausées
on n'est vraiment pas bien et le
lendemain on pleure on pleure on pleure
et après
excusez moi c'est d'être plus forte que
quasi ouais parce qu'il faut lui donner
[Musique]
à
ici
[Applaudissements]
on a vu une surprise et j'ai besoin de
votre compte
j'accomplis qui va rentrer sur scène il
y aujourd'hui c'est ton cadeau de noël
ça va passer à la louise détruit tous
en lieu en initiant une trace elle croit
qu'elle est à l'aéroport narita
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
si sa mort
il a bien compris que tu n'étais pas là
et rocco métier plutôt ton concert ici
avec ce magnifique public est chaud
convient tant pas penser à tout le monde
qu'il a aimée qui pleure devant et le
public regarde comme magnifique avec le
messie venu pour un type précis aussi
sur le point de tomber d'ici noël et
j'ai besoin de toi pour le faire tourner
le public était très bien avec moi quand
je trouve on les bat demain
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'était un truc de fou que tout de noël
en avance incroyable
l'autre merci c'est parce que ma bagnole
il est vraiment réussi tu peux te le
confirme et je suis très heureuse je
n'oublierai jamais ce moment qui restera
graver à jamais dans ma mémoire
merci
[Musique]
voilà
[Applaudissements]
larcher
ok mais exceptionnel encore bon c'est
l'inversé soprano vraiment qu'est un
type exceptionnel que j'aime fort et
sopra quand on lui a montré la vidéo
quand on lui a demandé
voilà de faire une surprise il a dit oui
tout de suite il a même pas hésité une
seconde c'est une bande de mecs c'est
pour ça que je t'aime frérot et que ça
fait des années que je t'aime et elle
voit katy et stéphanie remercie d'être
là ça va sûrement soir
[Applaudissements]
c'est génial c'est génial ce team sebah
comment décrire c'était fou j'ai
tendance qu'ils ont à peine la vie ah
ouais t'as vu charles amour ouais si il
faut que je le dise à tous les gens que
personne c'est cette personne elle est
incroyable elle a tellement d'augmenter
en elle j'aurai le distribue à tout le
monde ça c'est génial
bah ouais tu peux remercier ta maman
surtout parce que c'est pas ça être un
gros budget merci d'avoir été là bien
sûr vous suit et on vous souhaite un bon
ben wallace qui vont partir aussi dans
toute l'europe et le voyage c'était une
bonne mais pas qu'à moitié de ce qu'il
venait d'accomplir n'aura pas soprano
avec vous on ne peut pas être partout
les férias